moment toc toc toc spécial neige toc toc
toc c'est parti le premier on y verra
alors qui c'est yves il qui yves le ven
yves le ven yb
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi mais pourquoi la production
fait démarrer cette séquence à géraldine
maillet se dote déjà c'est une thalasso
pour être de le faire mais en plus ce
genre est là et ça va ma chérie mais je
me suis débarrassé comme simon d'accord
bah tu vois ça après tout les
générations bien un chemin bien fait les
gars t'as pas mal bon c'était nul
j'étais très bonne voie si vous êtes
très beau série ce soir si vous ne
rajoute pas combien tu vas t'asseoir
[Applaudissements]
c'est qu'en tant cantat qui
bravo nouvelle ville de nador écouté la
cassette et gérald abonnés du radis la
corde et du rallye oui c'est sûr ils ont
pas mis ton nom tu es trop connu non là
il est l'âme on aurait aimé se sont
trompés ils accord n'importe quoi tu vas
te mettre la taille est pas au club
icaunais pas du bon côté
voilà la vie chez sia le micro n'est pas
du bon côté
merci en tout cas merci c'était quoi la
chanson qui chantait les il faut la
mettre après derrière merci et je l'en
remercie mais ils ont bien là là mais je
peux plus tu allez on y va à tac toc toc
ou lima tac tac je connais se
reconnaissent à gâteau proulx s'est
redouane tusa redouane red one qui
redouane des neiges
[Applaudissements]
les jours vous avez une première réponse
y en a plein qui se demandaient si
agathe serait là ce soir ou pas eh bien
elle est là alors oui c'est vrai un et
les soutiens grande ouais c'est vrai ça
va mais que tu es là c'est mieux ça va
vous êtes bien là tous les trois on est
autant ses deux matches est contente de
voir agathe
ah oui ma vie c'est vrai tu l'as cliff
oui et benjamins c'est mon préféré
non voilà adore comment donner mission
non à leurs gardes en fait elle ne
regarde jamais les missions non mais
c'est vrai que c'est ont préféré oui
s'il verdez lui gilbert des débats il va
aller toc toc toc
ah non ça c'est pas du gard et c'est la
même chose c'est la même génération
dis donc tu as vacances et vous
reviendrez tout à l'heure c'est vrai
ouais parce que je voulais sans dernier
d'accord tu reviens là ma course a
terminé en fanfare mairie de salazie a
je crois savoir qu'il m'arrivait aller
les constructeurs doc
voilà qui est là c'est jean-michel mais
là
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi pourquoi non mais c'est vrai
vous l'aimez nommé sniper officiel tout
le temps de l'avent de la balle même
derrière l'appareil dans les bus à paris
mais qu'est ce que tu veux adopter la
jordanne jordan dit bah on m'a dit
german je sais pas
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
il se souvient plus des fêtes normale
alors que la chanson
[Musique]
magie la barre merci jean michel ça nous
aide toi non messieurs m haies et messi
ont déconné quand vous sentez je suis un
con vous sentez-vous de mieux en mieux
non vraiment c'est vrai mais je laisse
ma journée russie ben ouais c'est un
baber cérium et c'est pour ça que je les
aime ça fait vraiment penser tant qu'il
est heureux balle à la première 1er
avril 2010 voilà bravo
il a il a noté c'est le seul truc c'est
le premier jour il a courrier c'est ici
ma à ses pieds c'est même la poussière
emporte t rêve de l'umih
[Musique]
à cet égard et se sont prêtées ah oui il
parait l'open est là comme ça pour le
kiff
[Musique]
chroniqueur préféré je crois je vais
changer
bon allez je dois toc toc toc toc toc
toc c'est pas mais qui prime
oui à pattinson mais romero mais où la
houle acquis ou la la la
non
il vaut mieux qu'ils prennent les vend
maintenant way to try je sois il est en
prime time en direct son premier point
de thann et le fait en direct
en direct c'est un branchement pour le
premier à approuver circuit en régie ils
peuvent appuyer sur un bouton et lance
un téléfilm match comme ça si vraiment
c'est une cata total alors on fera ça
qu'on vous fait un spectacle on dirait
que ça sent le haut le prévoir à merci à
l'époque toc toc
voilà c'est qu'ils allouent de personnes
institutions
mais non bah ça ici c'est bon je vous
vois cbc ça j'y vais mais non c'est une
bonne fille mais si ces jpee qui gibert
est délivré
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
elle n'a rien à voir avec la reine des
neiges un placebo dans l'arène du cuir
on va naître chez cuir center beaucoup
c'est beaucoup moins reconnus qui est
avec nous bertrand badie tac tac c'est
isabelle il sèche et même plus qui sait
pas alors qu'ils n'étaient pas parfaits
[Applaudissements]
bur
alors si vous nous rejoignez la
variabilisation black des années 60 pour
chanter ça faut pas être man show
[Musique]
je gagnerai jamais un prime
[Applaudissements]